you're then minus one in the blitz today
but you're in third place mixed feelings
no no i'm actually quite satisfied with
my blessed score not not mixed feelings
at all um four out of nine is for me an
excellent scorer in the blitz so i
cannot complain i do think i had a lot
of luck in my games to get to this score
so
uh you know i'm just happy uh with the
with four of nine you want some crucial
games in today in today's rounds take us
through some of your favorite moments of
the day um well my luckiest moment i
remembered it was against maxine for
sure i mean i didn't
have any chance of winning and suddenly
i i won the game out of out of nowhere
and then like all the games are kind of
a blur so i'm just trying to recollect
um
oh i think i beat even savage in a kind
of nice game so that's about it and then
the games i lost i think i all lost them
quite deservedly so no complaints about
these games as well it sounds like
you're satisfied with 409 but you're
gonna need better than that to keep your
third place what what's gonna have to
change
yeah i just hope that maybe the guys
behind me will slow down a bit but uh no
i mean i i should i mean i should try to
gain some points uh to keep third place
of course um
but uh it's not gonna be very hard so i
just try to take it one game at a time
and i'll see where i end up i guess miro
in the studio thought that every player
that says that they're a bad blitzer is
lying are you just being falsely modest
or
i mean i'm comparing myself to these
blitz monsters i don't think i'm a good
blitz player like um i would beat most
people's but these guys are just like on
another level i would say they're just
so sharp and
so insanely good it's just
it's just very hard to play against them
and to score any points at all well they
can't be in that much of another level
you're currently in third place and
hopefully tomorrow you improve that a
little bit i'll try you know i'm i mean
i'm just gonna try to maintain third for
now and see see where it goes tomorrow
morning playing or tomorrow first game
against magnus is very nice of course
just to play against magnus in the first
round so looking forward to that game
and then we'll see how it goes after
that jordan van gogh is here in third
place in zagreb and tomorrow he's gonna
try to take down magnus carlsen and
reclaim even a higher score guys back to
the studio
thank you uh alejandro
four out of nine